(underage girl)
SKRATTA DU!!! *ehh*
So I'm a couple of days ahead of footage
I know
Sue me, what are you gonna do? (I think the question comes first Pewds)
Okay? (Okay)
First time ever I've managed to work ahead! (I'm so proud)
BUT(t)! *fart sound*
It looks like this finally it...
The sub-gap is less than 4000 :(
Which means, by the time this video goes up, T-Series would've passed me  (so sad Felix) :'(
I know
You're crying right now
I know you are, because it has already happened
*sadness*
Oh god
Oh god, it's moving fast
Ok this- LITERALLY a sinking ship here, guys
We need to have a good laugh
We need to have a good skratta
Let's go
*video plays*
*BoOmmM*
Woah (appropriate reaction there)
*same video and same reactions*
(laughs like psycho)
wOw iT loOks so rEaL :D
(laughs like psycho again)
THERE'S MULTIPLE CHANNELS???
Noooo not the dog! (laughs)
Video: "You can't show that on YouTube!"
Oh, I can't?
DAMMIT! *DEMONITIZED*
Oh well
T-Series has already passed me
It doesn't matter
Nothing matters
Depressed Pewds: Life doesn't matter... :(
What are you gonna do?
Cry?
Video: "You gonna cry?"
Pewds: Huh????
Video: Gonna piss your pants maybe?
Pewds: MAYBE I AM
MAYBE I AM
*attempts to avoid demonetization but fails*
I AM DOING THAT!
Video: "Just like those bankers on WallStreet?"
Pewds: YEAH
Video: The top 1%-
Pewds: Just like those- (gibberish as usual)
Video: ….stealing all the *oof* and *oof* from middle class walking people"
Pewds: (laughs)
*applause*
You're goddamn right
You're go-
Video: *starts over* yOu GoNnA cry?
Yeah, I AM
I mean, I'M NOT
I'm not crying (what do you mean im crying, im not. what do you mean i need help, i do not. what do you mean im crying out for help, i.. might)
*video plays*
*screech*
Pewds: Ok...
(chuckles) Jesus Christ
NO
I don't need this right now
I need a good laugh
C'mon
I don't even care about my health bar (when did you ever care?) LOL
*OOF*
I don't even care if I die
I'm gonna laugh
Cuz I need it
Ok, here we go
*video plays*
GODDAMMIT!
*heart attack(?)*
Ah, Ricardo *pewds falls in love*
He could possibly be the only one that can save us
Except we already lost...
So we can't be-
*ARGH*
I can't do this, it hurts too much
*video plays*
Ay, look its my channel
Before T-Series took over :(
Auuhhh AH (strange noises)
No! Not anymore feels...
Oh god...
I can't-
You Laugh, You Feels
*dramatises for a bit*
Give me a good laugh
Please
They say laughs can cure any cancer (who said that?)
Let's make it happen, guys (and gals)
C'mon
*video plays*
The hell is this? (chess?)
*eArtH QuaKE*
Oh....
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
(laughs)
Is this real?
I am so confused
Oh god
Heh HA
That was great
sMaSh LiKe!
Ok guys, next, we have a picture
of a... *reads picture*
Ok
*continues to read picture in normal pewds fashion*
That's the cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
*cue car alarm sound*
I'm not crying, ok?
There's a difference between tears of joy and tears of satisfaction (tHaT's WAhT They ALl sAY)
And when I see a snake,
MONCHING something, it makes me attraction (smh)
(chuckles) Ok, Jesus Christ
*video plays*
(laughs)
nOt tO bE rAcIsT, bUt wHaMeN
*ghuaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa* (btw guys how do u frickin write this sound...)
*video plays*
Oh god, no
No, I can't handle anything more sad
Don't do it
*yeets pickaxe*
(chuckles)
Super worthwhile! (laughs evilly)
Super worthwhile, this- do they - (laughs)
Aw...
No...
No, you are not that dumb
*yeets other pickaxe like dum dum*
Jesus Christ....
Oh My God
That is disturbingly stupid
Video: Interviewer: "What would say is the perfect man?"
(Pewds ofc)
Woman: "Perfect man..."
Woman: "Probably one that lasts longer than 5 minutes" *ROASTED*
Interviewer: Oh- (laughs)
Guy in background: *offended*
Pewds: (laughs)
Good meme
Very- very nice meme
I'm having a great time, by the way
I dunno about you, but
I'm having a laugh
What's my health bar (I thought you didn't care...)
You know what? Doesn't matter (o nevermind then u never cared anyways)
SCREW ma healthbar
I don't care (I knew it)
I'm not even gonna-
*rip mic*
...drink "glug glug" ok?
I don't care
I don't care anymore (when did you care exactly?)
I JUST DON'T CAREEEEE
*thud* NOO
See, I don't even care, I'm not even gonna pick that up
*video plays*
(padme is a phedo- CoUgH)
Hey look, it's Old Reality PewDiePie
Video: "...killing younglings"
Pewds: Not the younglings...
(ELON MUSK MEME REVIEWWWW)
Video: Elon: "Is that true??"
Pewds: (laughs)
Elon: "That- that actually happened?" (laughs)
Justin: "Of course it happened! I think- I think is a reflection of how...
Justin: "...like-"
Pewds: Pretty good
That's it, that's a new meme format right there
*video plays*
*smack*
"I did not hit her. It's not true."
"It's bullshit! I did NOT hit her!
"I did NOT."
"Oh Hi Mark"
Pewds: (laughs)
"Oh hi MARCH" is what he should say
There it is
Someone already made the joke
That's cool
*video plays*
I have seen this but it's still a great video
"I like him"
Thanos: "No homo" (ofc ofc)
Pewds: (chuckles)
Thanos not gay everyone
Can we add it in the comments please?
Thanos
Ain't
Gay
The f- am I saying?
Real cringe, man
*video plays*
Oh god
(chuckles)
(laughs)
Pewds: I've been in my nie-he *laughs*
Pewds: SOMALI! It detected
(laughs)
Pewds: Another 'ooga', please
Ah, my sides
I must be dying (trust me, you are)
I must be dying(you just said that)
What's my healthbar (I thought we moved past this feglix)
*glug glug glug*
I guess I have a little steam left in me, huh? (nah)
._.ptospstsptostspto
*video plays*
*ded*
Pewds: What? What is this?
*sad music*
Pewds: (chuckles)
Is that supposed to be a horror game or something?
(laughs)
What is that?
I'm so confused
Guys we have a couple more epic clips (ugh do we have to?)
Like, stop crying
STOP CRYINGGG (pewds really just talking to himself)
High Pewds: It's fine, its fun, it's fine, it's FINE (pewds trying to convince himself its alright even tho hes dying inside)
*video plays*
(I just noticed this is Felix reacting to someone, who is watching Felix, reacting to himself, who is reacting to felix asking for a brofist) *mind blown*
Oh god, are they gonna add another layer?
(laughs)
*Inhales heavily*
Now THIS IS THE KIND OF REAL ENTHUSIASM WHEN I ASK FOR A BROFIST!
(Hey, didn't you say we can't brofist unless we win the war?)
HA! Just kidding (rejected)
You broke your screen for nothing BI-*deafening bass*
*video plays*
(anime is re:zero for all my weebs out there)
Pewds: It's a SubARU! (what pronunciation felix????)
Pewds: See, this is where the demo...
I think- stopped for me
I don't remember
Oh wait
Maybe he comes later in this area
Pewds: YEEE
(laughs)
That was great
That was a good laugh
*Best Minecraft Music and Music in general*
Pewds: Hey look
It's diamonds
That's nice
*gasp*
Pewds: Noo
*explosion*
Pewds: It was only a dream
Just like I wanna wake up
Heh
From T-Series...
Passing me...
Only being a nightmare(oof man)
*surprise*
OH MY GO-HAHAHAHA
Guess my healthbar is... (FELIX WE MOVED PAST THIS MANY MINUTES AGO DIDN'T YOU SAY YOUDIDNTCARE!!?!?)
...has run out.
Well, I wanna say Thank You to all of you, for being by my side ( :D no problem bro - caption authors <3)
It's been an honor
But its time for me to go
OOF
*dies?*
Smash like, Subscribe, Buy the merch
*ded* lmao rip
*look at that little tuff of hair*
*beautiful hair*
Tuber Simulator is now so relevant
That's it's got a brand new MINIGAME!
CRANIAC!
Drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine-like game!
And you say there's more?
OF COURSE THERE IS
New Knowledge Perks!
New Quests!
And New Pixelings!
And LEGS! :O
Guys...
LEGS! (the one thing he doesn't have)
These captions took me 3 hours..[heh it took me like 20 min]... Still worth it XD) (Hey bro thanks for doing a great service to us other authors <3)